bonjour à tous je suis c'est cauet le
taq taq
aujourd'hui nous allons parler les
devoirs du citoyen que désigne-t-on par
les devoirs du citoyen les devoirs du
citoyen sont en quelque sorte la
contrepartie de ces droits au sens
juridique le mot devoir est le synonyme
du mot obligations
c'est donc ce que tout citoyen doit
faire respecter afin de vivre en
harmonie dans la société avec les autres
citoyens quels sont les devoirs du
citoyen le principal devoir du citoyen
d'un pays et de respecter les lois du
pays afin de pouvoir vivre ensemble dans
un pays organisé c'est l'assurance que
la liberté les droits et la sécurité
soit garantie pour tous nos devoirs de
citoyens sont de deux natures juridique
et morale ainsi chaque citoyen doit
d'abord respecter les droits des autres
qui sont identiques aux siens il doit
donc respecter les lois qui sont
identiques pour tous ce sont les devoirs
juridique et le devoir à dimension
morale
les citoyens doivent vivre en citoyens
pour cela il doit faire preuve de
civisme et de civilité latitude d or
vers les autres et très importante pour
rendre la vie en société supportable une
société sans politesse sans respect sans
la capacité à venir en aide aux
personnes en difficulté serait une
société où la notion de citoyenneté
serait soit fortement affaibli sont au
pire
inexistante y at il une loi ou une
charte qui définit les droits du citoyen
français
oui une charte existe et elle s'appelle
charte des droits et devoirs du citoyen
français prévue à l'article 21 24 du
code civil
son décret date du 30 janvier 2012 que
dix autres shorts
cette charte énonce les droits et
devoirs du citoyen résultant de la
constitution ou de la loi elle est
d'ailleurs remise à tous les jeunes
français qui effectuent leur journée
défense et citoyenneté
quels sont les devoirs écrits dans la
charte est de voir mentionné dans la
charte sont les suivants tout citoyen
doit respecter les droits inaliénables
accordé à chacun il doit concourir à la
défense nationale et participer au jury
d'assises il doit respecter la dignité
humaine
les enfants de moins de 16 ans ont le
devoir de suivre une instruction
scolaire tout citoyen doit concourir à
la cohésion du pays
chacun doit contribuer selon ses
capacités financières aux dépenses de là
a sion par le paiement d'impôts et de
cotisations sociales le citoyen doit
aussi contribuer aux charges communes de
son ménage et le droit de vote
n'est ce pas aussi un devoir citoyen la
charte des droits et devoirs du citoyen
français mentionnent que voter est un
droit
c'est aussi un devoir civique néanmoins
la loi n'oblige pas à aller voter
ce n'est donc pas juridiquement à devoir
disons que ce pourrait être un devoir
moral et civique
j'espère que vous avez compris ce que
sont les devoirs du citoyen français
à bientôt pour un nouvel épisode